you know the one thing we're hearing up
here in new york more and more
is of course the trevor lawrence
conversation
you know you we played the clip
yesterday the new york media's in dabo
swinney's press conference is down there
in clemson now and i just feel like with
trevor lawrence being like somewhat of a
football god in the world right now
if the giants had the number one pick i
don't know what they do i think it's
very dicey at this point can you pass up
trevor lawrence what do you think
well i don't think you can yeah i don't
think a lot of people think you can i
understand it what if it comes down to
the jets or the giants right 17
for the number one pick in the draft
look you said it yourself the
competition for the competition for the
first overall pick this year now the nfl
doesn't want anyone to think there is a
competition i think that's one of the
reasons why there isn't a draft lottery
which would be a huge event with
millions of dollars earned for the nfl
and millions of eyeballs tuning in to
see who gets the first overall pick they
don't want to give any credence to the
idea that teams would be tempted to not
try to win but when you have 10 teams
right now with one win or fewer and
borrowing a tie that will change tonight
it will drop to nine at least for now
because a lot of these bottom feeders
are playing each other starting with the
giants and the eagles when you have that
many teams that are already circling the
drain
you have to start thinking about
and this is an ownership front office
type thing we want to evaluate evaluate
the younger players we want to see what
the backup quarterback yeah right we
want to see what the third string corner
can do to julio jones right that that's
how it happens and i think some of these
teams are going to be very tempted to do
it and if you're the giants
and you've got the jets in your own
stadium
and they're positioning themselves
whether they want to or not for trevor
lawrence how do you not become tempted
to say
we're going to put guys on the field to
evaluate them and just hope nature takes
its course and we end up with the first
overall picture yeah i i know you're
right it's where it's really tricky and
it's tricky when you speak specifically
and i know we didn't mean to make this
right-hand turn about this conversation
but it is the giant still i mean they
told us we have times good we're good
but but but what is really tricky about
the situation and as we both know
you know yeah if you got the number one
pick jets or giants or if they're one
two whatever
yeah it's trevor lawrence uh you're
right you're rolling the dice if you
pass them up but the other issue that
both teams have is they have so
many
issues on their roster
like to where you want to go there's the
other football side of me goes you can
win with sam darnold and daniel jones
you can do it you just gotta build a
team around it you know yeah they're not
patrick mahomes or rogers and just gonna
carry the team and do stuff like that no
but they're really they're really good
football players uh and that's to me
gonna be the other part of that
conversation is you know what team wants
to go okay we got the quarterback or
what team's gonna go okay you know our
quarterback will deal with it we have so
many issues on our team we gotta figure
out the rest of the issues not the
quarterback
god if it just comes down to those two
teams i it's just it's fascinating me
and what about this what if trevor
lawrence says jets or giants no thank
you i'll just stay at clemson one more
year well i mean he could i wouldn't do
that if i was him i would never roll the
dice like that as you know i mean yeah
it's i know he's the man but you know
one
guy one defensive lineman tripping over
his feet or falling into your knee and
you might not be the number one pick and
the other thing i would say is hey
coming up here and playing football in
new york they're not it doesn't look
special right now but it is still pretty
damn special to be a player the city
loves football they love their jets and
their giants uh
and uh i think that would be hard to
turn around turn turned down
hey here's the other thing you can do as
well even though players don't do it
nearly as often as they should he could
do a power play he could do an eli
manning john elway style power play and
make it clear that he does not want to
play for a team that has no offensive
line or a team that is jim just mired in
dysfunction this is he wants to play for
this team this team this team whatever
and he's going to engineer it that way
you know i i fully support that because
situations like this underscore my
belief that the draft is unfair to these
athletes who should be able to pick
where they want to go with appropriate
protections put in place salary cap
mechanisms etc to keep teams from
stacking their roster with a bunch of
great young players and really who are
you gonna convince come sit on the bench
yeah right he's not gonna go play for
the chiefs and be the backup to patrick
mahomes he wants to go somewhere where
he can play and he wants to go somewhere
he thinks he can play well and and to
get drafted by the worst team i know
that's the way it works but it doesn't
have to be that way because we've seen
guys push back in the past
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports